Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
So Deadpool and
Spider-Man have a long history in the comics
Spidey pool became a thing a long time ago.
But one of the most meta-things that they've
ever done is basically switch places Deadpool
becomes Spider-Man and Spider-Man becomes
Deadpool, so him and explained that story.
There is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway
going on now to all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video be sure to click that bell, so
you don't miss out on anything.
So Deadpool becoming Spider-Man Spider-Man
becoming Deadpool.
There's a long history of Deadpool cosplaying
as other characters he is the biggest fan
of Spider-Man, Wolverine, he name dropped
Batman all the time, and there's been some
fan art that had him as Batman going all the
way back to Deadpool's first run in the comics
he's come across.
Spider-Man eventually they started teaming
up.
They even got their own title.
Spider-Man and Deadpool, so thus Spidey pool
was born out of their friendship.
There was appeared in the comics.
When he was superior.
Spider-Man when he was really Otto Octavius
in the body of Spider-Man when he really started
to heat on Deadpool but for the most part
they are super Brose and Deadpool one time
invoked the super bro code and became.
Spider-Man were his costume and Spider-Man
war Deadpool's costume to take down the chameleon
so and Deadpool annual number two.
Spider-Man keeps getting shanks by mystery
people.
He starts attacking random old ladies on the
street, shaking them the chameleon.
So Deadpool gets a brilliant idea as he tends
to do he's going to chameleon the chameleon
by taking on Spider-Man's persona, to try
and draw him out.
So even though.
Spider-Man's been kind of a jerk to him lately
just talking about superior.
Spider-Man Peter Parker is back the real Peter
Parker he wants to help him out super Pro
code.
I'm not can out someone secret identity.
He even fights off a bunch of office workers
that want to peek under Spider-Man's mask.
So Deadpool.
Spider-Man does a little bit of groundwork
takes a picture with a pretty girl finds out
that it's the chameleon and gets gained again.
But chameleon gets away.
So as he's swinging after him.
He starts to notice other people in trouble.
So decides that while he is wearing.
Spider-Man's costume is gonna do.
Spider-Man's duty and help people out just
like he thinks of Peter Parker would classic
Spider-Man scenario working his way up the
ladder from per snatchers he senses a bunch
of snakes going somewhere so realizes it's
an animal theme villain classic Spider-Man.
So he finds out that it's the master.
He's a snake theme villain totally calls them
out on his stupid plan.
These try to turn people at the giant mice
to feed his snake Army and says he is the
enemy of dumb and tries to defeat him, but
accidentally knocks them into his device,
turning him and his snake Army into a giant
Godzilla size mouse.
So even though Deadpool is enjoying a classic.
Spider-Man theme villain this story is very
much in the style of Deadpool adventures whereby
he starts out with a very simple problem to
solve, but in trying to solve.
It creates much bigger problems for himself
that he then solves a whole various ways.
So just snowballs out of control until he
hijacks a helicopter from the authorities
and throws it at the giant Godzilla mouse
defeating it.
But then outcomes the chameleon the person
that he was originally putting on the Spider-Man
costume to get in and Spider-Man resurfaces
in the Deadpool costume and they have a classic
Mexican standoff Clint Eastwood style the
chameleon emulates Deadpool Deadpool is forced
to choose who he shoots so finally.
Spider-Man says you're my amazing friend he
almost shoots him because he doesn't trust
it and then he finally just a size to shoot
them both and just happens to shoot the chameleon
first.
So then.
Spider-Man learns that the reason the chameleon
was able to track him is because of the upgraded
web fluid that Otto Octavius was using when
he was acting as Spider-Man Deadpool says
you should probably fix that.
So they take a lot of opportunities to make
fun of superior Spider-Man during this.
So this concludes amazing friend team up awesome
Spidey pool story but as you notice they do
like to make fun of themselves a lot anytime
they do a story where Deadpool is doing something
above and beyond his normal level of ridiculousness,
they always take as many opportunities as
possible to troll themselves.
They did the same thing I did a video about
how they were trolling Batman view Superman,
but really it was Deadpool trolling the Deadpool
movie, and Ryan Reynolds so well at a link
to that in the comments the closest we've
ever gotten to this actually happening in
the movies was the Deadpool movie or Ryan
Reynolds as Deadpool wore the Hugh Jackman
mask he such a trooper for allowing his face
to be used in that way I can tell you that
is earth two automated maybe nothing that
is there's a guy this masking same with that
you remember in this is the other, but the
really good friends.
So technically he wasn't becoming Wolverine.
Although now Ryan Reynolds is campaigning
behind-the-scenes to get Hugh Jackman to do
a Wolverine Deadpool crossover who knows if
that'll ever happen because were supposedly
getting are very last Hugh Jackman Wolverine
movie in a couple months but I wouldn't assume
anything until it actually goes down so they
will probably be liberal Wolverine Hugh Jackman
jokes in the Deadpool sequel.
And even though the Logan movie looks pretty
freaking serious there might be some Deadpool
in there somewhere just on the Easter egg
level, but in real life, you may have seen
some of the funny videos that Ryan Reynolds
and Hugh Jackman have posted back and forth
some to play these back to back then I'll
explain what there from good I'm Hugh Jackman
here, just reminding you to get your thoughts
in title sexiest man alive, Is coming out
that I a good day.
Sorry.
Ron Ramsey may connect him with my strength.
Doing a profit on the seventh on anyone.
You may remember me from such things as the
amazing 2010 six is minimal on 1250.
Who would've thought this or he is getting
hard to getting a stop, which will join the
ranks of the great Canadian such as William
Shatner Leslie Nelson Tommy Chong how can
a guy who filed his high school drama cost
be this talented millions to quit my favorite
actor in the world the greatest trunnion Hugh
Jackman and while I was table 6 Is Metallizing
Way before me.
Americans of the most generous country, so
feel free my section CZ that first clip was
actually from when they were still making
the Deadpool movie when Ryan Reynolds was
getting ready to be voted people sexiest man
the other clip is from more recently with
Hugh Jackman giving Ryan Reynolds a shout
out because he got a star on the Hollywood
walk of fame so that was a big moment for
Ryan Reynolds career then you realize like
how come they have been doing this the whole
time.
This to be so amazing you can make a movie
even if it was in a comic book movie which
is the two of them being ridiculous, but because
the Logan movie is coming up because Hugh
Jackman was a total sport when they were promoting
Deadpool you might see a lot more of this
Deadpool style humor going into March because
that's when the Wolverine movie is coming
when you start talking about Deadpool.
Spider-Man crossovers in the movies that's
like a long, long ways off.
Kevin Feige said there's currently no deal
to be made with Fox anytime soon, it sounds
like it's more of a fox they like they're
just not ready to make a deal with Marvel
yet but you have to remember all the drama
was Spider-Man at Sony.
They're all about rebooting the character
starting with something fresh at Marvel wants
that characters a little more mature was they
got a couple movies under the belt the be
ready for more fun Deadpool style humor like
this, but they're taking it pretty seriously
at the start of he well but with like a Spider-Man
sense of humor which is quite the same thing
is Deadpool but just like in the comics you
start out with a bunch of characters in their
own titles.
Then Stan Lee gets the bright idea to throw
them all together and make in avengers, comic
way way back and then eventually get Deadpool
style crossovers, the kind of make fun of
that thing, so really in the movies.
We've had our first couple big avengers team
ups eventually go get something that will
totally parody that you have more opportunities
for Deadpool.
Spider-Man style crossovers.
So don't worry will get there eventually is
just a before you can parody a team up like
that you have to have the regular team ups
first which is actually where were headed
in Marvel phase 3 and phase 4 way more crossovers
than you ever thought we were going to get
this to be so much Dr. strange in other people's
movies expect the same thing from Iron Man
just like he's going to be in the Spider-Man
movie.
Next, but in related news big trailers maybe
dropping really soon.
There have been rumors that the Justice league
trailer is gonna drop really soon.
So I'll do a video about Justice league in
the next couple days.
But new game of thrones new walking dead in
a whole much more marvel DC posting next week
so if you want to suggest any comic book characters
becoming other characters like Deadpool becomes
venom the entire marvel universe just became
benefited a much a variant covers if you want
to recommend the story just write them below
in the comments there's also going to be a
whole bunch of Star Wars next week to we gotta
talk about what can be happening next while
you guys wait for that to post you can click
here to watch the flash fight Iris West and
you can click here to rewatch the Spider-Man
trailer.
Thank you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight!